[Musica]
ciao ragazzi sono nascosta in questo
momento perché in questa challenge dovrò
trovare gli ingredienti slime nascosti
da g praticamente granny ha nascosto gli
ingredienti slime in giro per la casa e
il mio obiettivo è riuscire a fare lo
slime con tutti gli ingredienti nascosti
senza essere beccata da granny se non
conoscete cremi è un videogioco in cui
c'è una nonnina cattiva che si sente
qualche rumore ma chissà chiamata ci va
il più sereno possibile
se sente qualche rumore viene e ti
rincorre e ti colpisce con la sua mazza
e l'obiettivo è non essere colpiti per
più di cinque volte
altrimenti perdiamo il gioco quindi devo
riuscire a fare lo slime senza essere
beccata per meno non più di cinque volte
e recuperare tutti gli ingredienti per
fare lo slime quegli ingredienti sono
nascosti qua per casa e non so dove sono
tra l'altro è buio perché crei mista al
buio e ho un sacco di paura che ora esco
all'improvviso lasciato un bel mi piace
se volete vedere oltre sull entità del
genere e grazie per averci consigliato
questa challenge perché ce l'avete
consigliata a voi perché sono un sacco i
video con granny ho visto che vanno un
sacco di moda su youtube america sono un
sacco di pd o challenge con grammy e
piacciono tantissimo su youtube italia
ho visto che l'hanno fatta un canale che
si chiamano di insieme del super
divertente andate a vederla poi non so
perché mi piacciono così tanto perché
avete deciso di farmi fare questo senso
perché forse la sua lancia più
inquietante che abbia mai fatto
comunque allora c'è anche parlino
mandarli nostra tormento guardate è lì
che dorme quindi non mi aiuterà a
riuscire a capire se credi si sta
avvicinando perché sapete che i cani
hanno un super udito io spero che mi
aiutasse invece sta non tanto andiamo
alla ricerca del primo ingrediente che
suppongo che sia la colla ma potrei
anche trovare ingredienti in sparsi
insomma casuali e speriamo di trovarli
tutti
ok ragazzi sto andando in giro per la
stanza
vediamo se trovo qualcosa guardate c'è
una colla cimaschi musica è una colla
in al buio cuomo però è circondata da
delle bottiglie e penso che questa sia
stata un'idea di granny perché vuole che
io inciampi nelle bottiglie faccia
rumore
quindi devo riuscire a prendere quella
con la stanza a fare il rumore
oddio ce la farò oddio abbiamo piano
piano piano piano
[Musica]
ok ragazzi cerco di avvicinarmi piano
piano
piano piano
[Musica]
oddio la vetrina da g
che tifano aiuto sia la porta
oddio un abito e lino facciata
[Musica]
spero sia passata
ok non si fa sempre procediamo proviamo
a prendere la colla
[Musica]
ok è uscita bene o male non mi ha
beccato tra l'altro
bravo ok proviamo ora a prendere la
corda
[Musica]
chiaro chiaro piano piccola
per il piano piano piano piano
aiuto
[Musica]
ok ragazzi secondo giorno ancora tre
possibilità per riuscire a prendere
tutti i credenti slime non è iniziata
molto bene spero di farcela allora
questa volta deve essere più silente sia
possibile da prendere ma la colla
[Musica]
eccoli la colla
stare attenta e molto cauta ma non far
cadere
niente altrimenti oddio è fatta domanda
guardate che bella questa colosseo fino
a ok ora la riporto non è la mia
postazione nascosta
su bruciato qua così poi riuscirò a fare
il flight non forza che allora sto
controllando qua in questa stanza ma non
mi sembra di vedere altri ingredienti
steline quindi penso che forse devo
cambiare stanza
purtroppo poiché si deve essere qualcosa
non trovo niente aspetta un aumento
che cos'è quella cosa rosa ma è la
palette ho trovato la paletta così non
dovrò mischiare lo stand con le mie mani
sporcarmi vi ho già due cose quindi cosa
si occupa restando super bene mi è
sembrato i siti un rumore ok allora un
punto la valenza nella mia postazione
[Musica]
ecco qua e ora prova uscire dalla stanza
e cosi ripeto se trovo tutti gli altri
ingredienti l'importante è trovare
l'anti fatto che adesso devo trovare la
soluzione parlanti il bicarbonato di
sodio assolutamente altrimenti non
riesco ad attivare lo slime aperto
quindi andiamo a vedere nelle altre
stanze
[Musica]
che cos'è questo rumore
forse treni sta provando a centrare che
faccio per una porta in corsa ha chiuso
la porta a chiave
questo fare adesso non mi ricordo cosa
bisognava fare nel videogioco
devo trovare la chiave forse ma dove può
averla nascosta o se li ha chiuso la
porta dall'esterno può dire che lei ha
la chiave
quindi devo farla entrare farlo entrare
così apre la porta ma se entra poi mi
prenderà subito rapito con nascondere
sperando che non prenda merlino ok
allora devo fare rumore poi mi nascondo
dopo 3 nascondere
forse dentro l'armadio vediamo se c è
spazio
ok mi nascondo dietro l'armadio e e una
volta che se ne va non posso uscire
dalla stanza per cui funzioni
ok allora ho deciso di provare a fare
rumore con la bottiglia dopo essere
velocissimo altrimenti mi becca allora
ecco qua
ok siamo dentro l'armadio
nato
sta cercando melo quale non ha visto nel
sito
beh si no vieni qua
ciao amore da vito crimi
ok sei andata per fortuna che prosegue
la corsa
beh
capisco
[Musica]
motivo
no marino che quando il mio
vino di qualità
ok ragazza ha funzionato la porta è
aperta
quindi posso uscire dalla porta a
cercare gli altri ingredienti però
lasciato qualcosa per terra non capisco
che cos'è
ma qualcosa di appuntito che cos'è poche
ragazze proseguiamo video che cos'è
questa cosa
a rischio
massei
va bene
proviamo a saltare scavalcarla
[Musica]
pazzi giorno 3
purtroppo credimi ha beccato di nuovo
con quella trappola ma non ci casco più
cercherò di allontanarmi completamente
non inciamparci sopra questa volta
allora abbiamo ricominciato d'acqua
dalla stanza però anch'io so nuovamente
a chiave quindi devo trovare un altro
posto per nascondermi perché ho paura
che lei abbia capito che stavo dentro
l'armadio quindi penso che salirò sopra
il letto così non mi vedrà sicuramente
darà sopra quindi ora salgo le scale
[Musica]
ok ragazzi sono sopra letto mafia quanti
mi nascondo dietro stitch
ok ragazzi sono sopra il letto
vedete quindi posso osservare gremi
dall'alto e aspettare che apre la porta
però mi sono dimenticata di fare il
rumore con la bottiglia che perché non
facilmente possa dire sul letto poi
quindi lancero uno di questi pupazzetti
così farà rumore quale lanzo poverini
ok penso che lanciò l'unicorno speriamo
che sia abbastanza per farla interne
alla camera
pronti
[Musica]
eccolo
una per fortuna non ci ha visto ora la
porta è aperta
proverò andare nell'altra stanza vedere
se c'è la soluzione per lenti e il
bicarbonato così possiamo finalmente di
ballo slime speriamo di non essere
beccati che ragazze sono scesa dal letto
ora proviamo andare nell'altra stanza
sempre molto piano piano chi ha capito
piano piano piano
sta scegliendo la scala
resta ok per fortuna è andata quindi
forse avrò il tempo di trovare gli
ingredienti berlino tu che ci fai
ma come hai fatto in tre senza essere
visto da granny non è che sei un'alleato
di grendi magari e le stai facendo la
spia che stai dicendo tutto che sono
ogni sta risalendo
[Musica]
ok andata dall'altra stanza per fortuna
che vediamo in giro se ci sono che
importantissima partissi berlino
aiutami a trovare gli ingredienti slime
berlino ma perché dormì sempre mi
potresti aiutare a trovare gli
ingredienti merlino non ti fa proprio
paura e g niente
berlino è troppo stanco per aiutarmi ma
ce la farò riuscirò a trovarci per
trovare il bicarbonato di sodio e la
soluzione per l'ente e poi posso
attivare lo slime c'è una trappola anche
qua questa volta devo stare super
attenta ecco qua potete
stavolta non mi frega perché l'hai
eviterò completamente ci posso fare
guardate la soluzione per letti occupata
marchino seif ha detto l'ho trovata ma
che ho trovato la soluzione per lenti in
giappone tempo stesso la testa alunni
affari dopo umore con il rumore questo
corposo forse mi disse lo portò a terra
una disfatta ogni piano
piano ma riscatto al piano terra
ok ma così tanto rumore piano viola
forse si faceva ti sei fatta caccia
[Musica]
ok ragazzi giorno 4 o solo oggi e domani
per trovare il bicarbonato altrimenti
perderò la challenge
devo anche trovare una ciotola per
mestiere lo slime altrimenti dovrò farlo
per terra o sulle scale sporche o bhutto
quindi spero di riuscire a trovare una
ciotola ok siamo nuovamente nella camera
di partenza e merlino sta facendo rumore
perché sta musicando qualcosa il pupazzo
che avevo lanciato per grandi lascialo
berlino il mio dumbo poverino la sala
berlino per un vuoto che distrugga il
mio dumbo berlino lasciano lascia lo
lasciano
ok l'ho salvato per poco e un po oddio
la un po rosicchiato bene ma almeno sono
riuscito a salvarlo quanto el'altro
pupazzo recuperato ma che morda anche
lui sapete che merlino distrugge tutto
vai piano se no arriva premi come
facciamo se arriva grandi amori ok sto
curando pare intorno per vedere se c'è
qualcosa qua a mano su un po black devo
ritornare là non voglio tornare in
quella stanza era piena di trappole di
coorte dove potrebbe essere il
bicarbonato
fammi pensare a chi no cosa stai
cercando di dirmi che qualche strano
merlino s'è voluto appoggiare qua e
forse poteva che i bicarbonato equa lì
c'è il mio libro ma certo il bicarbonato
stupisce il mio libro perché con il mio
libro puoi fare il display quindi
ammesso il bicarbonato dove puoi
imparare a farli slime e quindi dopo il
mio libro c'è anche la ciotola
se riusciamo a non essere beccati forse
riusciamo a fare lo spread direttamente
adesso però dobbiamo fare piani primo
piano piano piano piano ok
ecco qua ecco qua arrivano che berlino
quindi devo mettermi più in alto questa
lo slime altrimenti mi arrivò pure
mangiarsi tutto vedete che è un curioso
ne lascia lido berlino vuole mangerebbe
a paletta rumore di pezzi ho appoggiato
alla camera ora mettiamo tutti gli
ingredienti per lo slime speriamo che
non arrivi g
ecco qua la colla che si illumina al
buio o allo zio paura anche primi da un
momento all'altro in berlin e smettila
di fare rumore altrimenti arriva grilli
siamo quasi attivo segreti non arriva
adesso abbiamo vinto la sarnese
no sto facendo troppo rumore o no no
così tanto rumore siamo quasi
guardate sei pronto un nuovo aspetta
però da slime è pronto quindi in realtà
io ho bit channel su perché non sei in
vacanza attiva è scomparso ceduto sono
riuscita a fare lo slime al giorno 4 che
ho vinto la challenge grenier scoperta a
the news live si lui no che al buio
caffè no ma ora che credi non c'è più
può tornare la luce in questa stanza e
finalmente la luce del sole che bello
che sto solito è stato stufo di
divertente anche se ho avuto un sacco di
paura tutto il tempo
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere una seconda parte
se questo video supera il 20 mila mi
piace fare un secondo forte
fateci sapere nei commenti qual è il
momento che vi è piaciuto di più o che
vi ha spaventato di più e ora vi lascio
a quattro case linee su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri case su quella che
preferite e buona visione
[Musica]